[Music]
people love the film safety not
guaranteed and you've already won an
award for it first of all what award did
you win I won the young Hollywood award
Oh sweets you'd have to give a speech
for this yes I wasn't required to but I
did give one yeah are you happy with how
the speech won I think so of what I can
remember of it I think I said thank you
thank you to young Hollywood for this
award thank you to all the young people
you old people
I'm going to live forever and then I
walked off
[Applause]
okay so you took what's a big comedy
risk there with that speech how did it
work out for you just silence there was
a lot of young people there a lot of
young people a lot of really young
people that's right okay
oh great oh well so there were like
children there oh yeah oh well yeah you
know for the for the televised you know
I did it for myself I don't know why I
did it I'm sorry next question nope
they're all about that speech didn't you
I read interview with you're not said
you look forward to getting old so here
you are you making a joke about oh
people but you you say you you want to
get up yeah I actually have a weird
fascination with old people when I was a
kid I really wanted to be an old woman
do you wanted to be an old yeah because
I feel well I felt and I still feel like
old old people can kind of do whatever
they want like they can get away with
anything and when I was a kid I used to
go to the mall I know you know those
mall fountains like the pools in the
middle of the mall I always thought that
if I was an old person like an old lady
I could jump in there and swim around
and you know I'm like they wouldn't like
arrest me because I could be like I'm
old yeah like that could be an excuse
for everything but if I'm a kid and I
get in there and I splash around like
they're gonna kick me out right right so
someday I'll do that